warzone rated 54 players currently
average rating 17 93 check that 56 check
that 57 58 more people jumping in here
we go
30 minutes
craziness here we go
thunderhorse land give me this timer
where is it at
okay it's out of my way ah i hate not
having bishop hans
start me out with start me without a
knight
but not without my bishop ons whatever
you do
let me keep my bishop pawns
i want to get to the f4 square dark
square bishop's off knight f4 landing
looking for mates
tricky mates more development get this
pawn up but the night plays here maybe
or not let's keep this pawn push could
be coming soon more development
take this night out keep my knight here
queen here
watch out for trickiness knight here is
available
it doesn't quite work i want to play
this i'm the bishop and i have a mate
threat
i'm on a mate threat again bishop takes
pawn is available
uh-oh i think i pile up here it's i'm on
it again
tricky tricky tricky tricky
i'm just gonna pick up this rook
and then okay we could trade a little
bit clock situation where are we at with
the clock
forks
got a nighter rook i got the knight
more pieces let's back up
right here
give check
give another check take this rook
they're down they're back they're down
they're back to tournament i was ready
to say
two two a bunch of twos and ones
28
seconds and change
springsteen
okay
let's go here
you know you want a castle
don't try to take out my uh my number
one guy here
get out of there night
pawn push if the knight plays there
let's stop him from even playing there
bishop takes pawn is available it's been
available how do they how does my
opponent castle knight here okay let's
stop it from playing there
um let's get here because the bishop
here was threatened okay i'm gonna get
this pawn back at least one of them
queen trade i want to avoid it kingside
castle target
f7 they're going in reverse
the knight wants to get here let's stop
it
okay i'm getting a pawn back i still
want to keep the queens on the board i
need my bishop out
and i need to target this i should
probably come back to defend a3
get my queen over to g3 and then
something like rook here i think is good
oh they were being sneaky very nice
very nice
and i think this works if i did the
calculations correct
i think that's working at the end of it
i'm on the bishop
i'm gonna take here take here and then
push these pawns hopefully they're fast
enough
they're fast enough
the king needed to play to h7 there
clock situation is fine
let's check where's that mate that's me
back to term at six
six six five five
not easy to win
not easy to win king's attacker
let's go
okay more development okay i get a
center
and let's keep it a little bit closed
let's give a check oh the king has to
move or the knights have to go back
okay
let's do this and then this and then
here
and then i have a pawn push actually i
don't because this is pinned no i could
do this my queen is guarding it
connected past pawns
oh a fork they missed it
i have the rook
for free no not for free
guard this pond i'm dropping this pond
though
you gonna see it
they missed it
let's do this open up the a file
okay let's take that
and i'm gonna take this and then just
take this i'm on f2 no no no
okay yeah it's okay
there might be a bishop check there is a
bishop check i'm on f2 i'm going to take
f2 there's checks
more checks i want to get to e3
where's that e3 square i'm going to do
this and then i'm taking the bishop and
i'm on the rook
on that rook
and i don't want to attack the knight oh
i'm on the rook they missed it
let's do this
hang on let's come here i'm going to
grab that pawn and then push it away
hang on
keep pushing
keep pushing
keep pushing
take the knight and then push again
they're going to resign
no resigns
check
check and then mate okay back to
tournament 12
12 11 11 10.
oh
tough
very tough
a lot of time left as well
and a lot of people are right up there
oh
no queen knight
no queen knight
so let's try an accelerated thunder
horse and that involves not doing the
baby step with g3 and then bishop
g3 and then g4 but just g4 in one shot
let's keep going
this needs to open up they're going to
go in the other direction let's come
over here now
i'm on the bishop
i don't want to take it i like my night
better
kick this night away
where's he gotta go he's going home is
he too good for his home he's not too
good for his home
or he is too good for his home
you take my knight no okay i want to
avoid this get to this square no my
queen wants to be my bishop is dead
let's do this stop the knight to a4
stuff knight right here i'm on the queen
bishop here and then get in a5 but no if
i do that then there's a pawn break i
don't want to allow for that
they're trying to trade pawn push here
is not good i guess we're going to see
pawn push right now let's do this in
between i do this with the fork to
follow fork to follow i'm on the bishop
and i got a fork
okay i got the piece back
and um let's open it up over here clock
situation is um
let's guard this
open up the a file
open up that a file i want to um put
pressure here we're gonna have a queen
trade maybe my bishop will be good on d4
let's get rid of this knight
make that happen
how are we going to have this uh
recapture
okay
my bishop is pretty decent here
i have a pig one pig on the seventh
looking for another pig and it's
unstoppable it's an unstoppable pig mate
threat mate in one
king here it's a maintenance one two
three or something with the check
it's a main one
back determined i got it
20 20 19 up there 20 20 and 19.
okay
oh these are tough
these are very tough no queen side minor
pieces
oh quick resigner
they were fearing me having no queenside
minor pieces
um
no bishop puns okay
uh is this person gonna move
are they gonna move 22 minutes and
change left
a lot of time a non-mover here's the
clock situation they are not moving
this person loves to check
that's their name loves to check
okay i love to
do some homework
so let's do some homework
here we go
harry potter is here
harry potter has 29
and he's playing against honey
honey 2010
okay things look pretty good for white
things look good for mr potter
12 seconds i'm not gonna get double the
double points is not in effect in this
game
okay i gotta close out of this my game
is starting in less than five here we go
oh 21 minutes remaining back to
tournament land leaders leaders leaders
leaders leaders 36 29 21 20 20 20 20 20
a lot of 20s
here we go
double the points last time my opponent
resigned when i didn't have the
queenside minor pieces they're not
resigning this time
clock situation
are they going to move the points have
been doubled
so if i get this win then that's it
not that
i didn't mean that
not that it's over i mean
if i win i'm getting the full amount of
points
i think
okay let's get out of the nonsense
avoid the nonsense avoid those tricks
bishop g7
they're going um they're going slow
let's do this knight here i don't want a
pawn break in the center maybe i should
have done this first
okay this knight is uh ready to be hit
with my queen queen d7 stuff
knight e7
let's go knight queen d7
oh it's defended now maybe i can break
it this
okay i get a pawn at least
i'm on the night i'm on this pond i
could give a check here if the queen
blocks i get the knight
okay the knight is in a pin i could take
here maybe
i could play here as well
or not here
20 seconds knight c6 c5
let's get out of silliness 18
16 15 let's just run anywhere
any move
don't do here don't pull your bishop
here let's come here anything
anything time burners where are you
anything at all night here grab a pond
any move i don't want any time to come
off my clock
they have no time they're down on time
down on time 50 50 41 33
30.
um everybody is everybody's up there um
19 oh wolf man it's tough enough being a
wolf man
with the regular set of pieces
with all the pieces
and now less time against the wolf
wolfster
to go quick
come over here i have a like a
ready-made uh grand prix attack
let's get rid of this
i'm gonna take my knight
don't take my knight okay while i get
this over here
night moves i play here
uh oh
uh oh you must be scared
oh
they are scared are they scared pawn
push here
over here d6
oh i forgot that that could even be
taken
i get d6
otherwise it was made if the king takes
i'm on the bishop let's do this stop the
bishop from moving if pawn takes my
knight has a wonderful square
oh now it doesn't have a good square now
it does
i can rely upon this pawn now
rook here pawn push
why am i not moving let's try this
my rook is kind of stuck
actually i want my rook on h1
oh this is scary what's the clock
situation oh they got rid of that
there's a queen check oh is that scary
i can get here with check they're not
they're not allowing that with here i'm
still trying it
okay is this okay i have to sidestep a
double check
and then i could take here with check
right here i think i need to take this
pawn
no i want to take this rook and then cut
the king off no i can't cut the king off
let me get this pawn though
oh why did i take the pawn
okay i gotta get king position my rook
needs to stay right here stay put rook
you have a job and that job is to watch
over the pond
don't do anything but watch over that
guy
actually my rook wants to
be over here
okay
holding my breath
they're down in time
there you go hold your breath defense
oh man
oh why does it have to come down to that
a rat race every time
a rat race
a mouse race oh man what an adrenaline
rush
oh man
i'm lightheaded i'm wobbly right now i'm
wobbly
move your pieces move your pieces how
many misclicks are you gonna have you
just dropped a bishop
you're down two pieces now
that's what you get
that's what you get i don't want to
trade they probably expected that
oh i got a pond for it
oh i'm on the night give me a piece back
oh the knight's going to kill me right
here i know it oh oh oh i got the queen
i got a queen
i got the queen never fear domino effect
pieces falling everywhere bishops hit
rook's pin the rook is hit
pile up on pin pieces kill the knight
and land a fork
they they're landing a fork on me
kill a rook
kill that rook and hit it with the pin
again oh check followed by check and
then mate
mate mate just move you know you want to
move don't be a time burner yes they
weren't a time burner
84 82
78 72
no rook
i could hit this guy with the blue
chicken gam but no but they resigned
they were fearing the blue chicken
gambit
the bcg
there is no bcgd
there is no blue chicken gambit declined
if it's if i want it to be accepted the
accepted version it will be accepted
there's no avoiding it
okay
hang on you don't have a queen night
don't get nervous
don't get nervous
give me the dark square bishop would you
please
let's go h pawn do something
for team uh
for team black
okay
can i get a piece back
they're gonna take my dark square bishop
i'm gonna hang on to my light square
bishop if they uh
okay let's do this they have the f4
square i'd like to be able to take that
away i'm gonna castle
bump my king up or bring my bishop back
let's bring it back break over here
or guard this pond a little bit i should
probably guard that pawn a little bit
land a fork
too scary i don't want to do it
watch out for the scary uh
moves there pawn push we're going to be
seeing h4 time is
time is uh tied right here i want to get
to this square maybe we could run this
pawn all the way down i can't move this
rook really knight takes here might be
played let's come over here defend stuff
can i keep going knight here i back up i
might have to part with my dark side
bishop i don't want to do that i don't
want a loud night here night here is
happening i could feel it
oh man this is scary please say it's
okay
please say it's okay
queen's off i think i'll be happy
come on you know you want to trade
queens trade queens
can i get this
rook lateral movement from my rook
get this pawn going
pawn push
keep going pawn go go go go go your pass
you know your pass run for a touchdown
move your rook i get the pawn check
i have this
i think
10 seconds this is enough time don't
drop your rook you would have just
dropped your hook
clock situation
trade trade queens give a check on c6
they're down on time back to tournament
124 122 116. thunderhorse land
no queen rook blue chicken gambit
i'm not gonna do it though i had my fun
with that
it's where you castle without the queen
rook and your opponent runs out of time
that's how it works if you're unfamiliar
g4 knight right here is good
it's still good it's no longer good
g5 h5 piece is getting pushed around the
h file is opening up queen to h5 coming
up looking for mate next mate next mate
next queen takes knight
uh oh
that's mate that's mate that's mate that
was a quick mate back to tournament 144
136
122 91
oh these are brutal
absolutely brutal
i'm gonna take this and try to work with
it
make it work
make it happen here oh man
why did i allow this
oh
scariness everywhere
scariness
scary
oh i'm getting mated are you kidding me
i'm getting mated
you can't weasel out of this can you
run away king you know it's safe on h7
you know it's safe here the night's
gonna give a check
i need some i need some room i need some
breathing room where's the breathing
room
i think night there would have killed me
real soon i got to get rid of that
bishop you need to go bishop
queen's off the board is this savable
i should have been dead a long while ago
just take
take my queen help me develop would
you can i play here i want to get that
pawn
can i get that pawn clock situation pin
a knight oh you can't move through
pieces
oh let's come back here how do i develop
okay get this pawn
throw a pin in there oh pigs pigs pigs
pigs pigs
right here right here
i think i need to
take here and i have to defend this pond
what a sad situation
take this knight uh
can i get this 16 seconds where are the
time burners i need to run this pawn
run pawn you could do it you're fast you
know you could do it you're really fast
you know you could do it you know you
could do it run pun he's gonna become a
queen he's gonna become a queen he's an
animal he's an animal
no don't drop your queen clock situation
i think i'm pulling a houdini i think
this is a houdini line
i wasn't supposed to win this one i got
a rook giving check no no no don't mouse
slip
clock situation give a check
over here
right here over here grab pawns this one
and then this one
that was another must slip
i wasn't supposed to win that one what
happened there
wow my king was running for the hills
right in the first 10 moves
oh was i nervous
was i nervous a quick resigner
184 back in first
184 176 130 121 one oh this guy
i have to play this guy without my um
okay how could i make this work
well i got the pawn back
i got that pawn back
oh no no no what's going on here watch
out for the rookie
let's do this and then this
move what move your pieces
move your pieces here let's do this i
think things are looking pretty good or
are they
gotta get that queen out of there oh i
am a dead man
again the same thing is happening
pawn push
oh this is ugly pawn push i have to give
up my light square bishop and stuff
please is it gonna be okay over here
oh please say it's gonna be okay
please say it's gonna be okay please
please please
oh they're on my bishop
oh this can't be good can it
just take just take just take let's
trade
oh i can't get out of this pin
knight right here i'd do a block
oh a fork following up catch him in a
pre-move
nope
i can't possibly win this can i no
no you can't win
you can't possibly win can you
no don't even try it oh i just dropped a
pawn that's brutal and there's forks
right around the corner and discover
checks everywhere 20 seconds oh peace is
dying
come on be a fighter can i somehow get
this
can i get a bishop or something come on
weave a mate
weave a mate come over here i need a
time burner
give a check
ah
oh that's mate that's mate that's me
oh that's mate still
they're having fun
here can i give some checks that's me
that's been made i should have resigned
196 182. oh my king was not a houdini in
that game
ah you can't be houdini with every game
lancaster will give you a beating
oh
man i had some hope though i had some
hope you have to believe me when i say i
felt like i had some hope there
oh
he had something else to say about that
though he's like you will have no hope
in this game
okay let me get this pun
let me get this file
my knight wants to be where
where does he want to be
no no let's not do that pawn push
my knight wants to be right here coming
up
incoming
let the dark square bishop play the game
let him play
lock down on the lights dark squares you
know what i meant
dark squares my queen wants to be over
here i think
um
hang on
line this up hit the queen and then come
back
watch out
watch out pawn push right here c4
queen back and then bishop here
queen back here
let's come over here open up the a file
maybe
my queen is maybe close to being trapped
what's that night up to
let's close this up rook here
that knight is doing a lot of dancing a
real lot of dancing
oh what's that what's that about
what is that what is that about
okay they're um they're waiting to get
killed i think rook right here on c5
small improvements
and now open this up
okay now i get this a pawn rolling shift
my queen back with a6 to follow okay now
i have the bishop or something
i got the queen and then the bishop
and then this
and then this
and then
where's the mate mate in one or two
main one or two
that's one that's one main one back to
tournament 202 whoa 236 202 195 191 170.
i'm the breed
five minutes and change
five minutes and change
uh i can't get first now there's no way
i'm just trying to hold second can i
hold second or can somebody knock off
that top guy
let's do this before i open the diagonal
towards my king
oh
man
h6 knight here g5 g4
let's take this knight
and then close shop
my knight wants to be over here the g
file
coming up trying to prep it a bit more
as soon as my knight plays there i think
it needs to be taken
i think it needs to be taken right now
and the rook is going gonna contest this
file okay the queen gets to come out and
play
tough to defend this the bishop has to
come back but then i preserve my knight
let's open this up
bishop takes knight i think is still
there let's try it again making one
threat
mate in one it's a pinned piece
look right here seems like it might be
good
oh wait
that's mate and one
oh i miscalculated
let's do this i want to get the queen
queen here is correct
uh
rook takes queen back
they're going to resign 20 seconds
that's me that's mate that's mate that's
me back to tournament 222 256 222 215
211
190. four minutes
mega
megazav
okay
um
okay
let's get developed
and well let's keep it closed
after after all that bishop check i have
to block here
okay let's stop that
and can i pick up that light square
bishop
i am picking it up and i want to do this
or this i'm going to do one square i'm
not my bishop on h3
i'm going to try and expand okay let's
stop that from opening up g3 this
there's going to be a c5 break coming up
um i want i want to come right here with
my bishop get on this diagonal and also
stop knight here and queen d7 stuff my
knight where can it go
i'm going to cash in at least get a pawn
back
might be a queen trade i'm going to
avoid the queen exchange if that happens
knight d2 my knight wants to be on g4
g4 coming up and then maybe f5 or
something
i could castle right did i start without
a rook
i could castle
let's do that
lock this up actually now g4 knight g3
is best i think g4 is best right now for
black
okay i have this but now the queen is
coming over here i think i have to do
this
to defend my bishop then this pond falls
and i need to trade queens and come back
they don't have any time though
no time 10 seconds i'm gonna just do
anything
just come back here
just castle
give a check
clock situation where are we at
anything and he moves back to chairman
twenty two fifty four two fifty four two
forty two two thirty one two twenty
three two minutes
two minutes twenty four
okay if that guy loses and i win my game
i think i could get it let's see if i'm
right
gotta win first you have to win first
this is probably the last game
bishop there is no good bishop here
let's try this
and then this
and then this
fantastic commentary yeah just keep
saying this and this and this that's the
way to do it
you know you want to just keep saying
that pawn push get a knight here
just take my knight and then i'll bring
my bishop
okay let's clamp down here that that
could be one
take the knight and then take the pawn
i want my bishop here i think okay now i
want to maybe get this move in but not
so quick pawn push i have this over here
could take this pawn let's come over in
this direction since that's where the
king is
let's come over here now
take that knight but actually that's
very valuable uh dark square bishop
let's take here and then this and then
i'm on b2
b2 is targeted twice difficult to defend
hit twice three times
pawn could push
i could take here with check and i'm
hitting everything
check and i think i smashed through at
this point there can't be a save can
there
i'm gonna go with the queen
mate next move it's mate it's me it's me
back to tournament
back to tournament 262 i have a lead
that guy fell back 262 254.
can i get one in there's 52 seconds left
would this guy resign if i have a good
position
oh can i get it can i get it can i get
it can i get it
um just come here can i get this one
oh just give me that file
i'm on the rook
don't take my bishop don't take my
bishop don't take my bishop
okay they didn't take my bishop
come on let's go here in the center so
it's 23 seconds
pawn push can i get twice
i'm going to try this this um f6 let me
get an f6
i want to get an f6 f6 with check come
on just move just move just move just
move they're going to take the pawn
they're going to take the pound
otherwise it's mate
oh they're going to take the pawn now
they're going to take it like that ah
one second left one second left
oh there's no hope they're ready to just
make me there what do we have what do we
have what do we have what do we have
second
oh so close
i had a glimmer of hope right there a
glimmer
difficult to go undefeated in that
tournament harry potter
274
262 243 230 229 194
tough tournament
very very tough tournament at the end of
it all
there were 94 players so people
were entering as the tournament went on
good games all